he had no idea
I hate great handsome funny a powerful
and he's got that beautiful bald head I
mean I have hair but it's thinning on
top and I don't have the guts to shave
it all off because I don't know if it'll
look good what in the name of God do I
do
introducing the power dome the quickest
easiest way to become a confident bald
man without actually losing your hair
Wow how are you Scott Ritter CEO why yes
I am
Ed Harris you're fired you're fired
you're fired
I just had sex in the supply closet
finally if you have a mom and dad call
them on the phone don't text them
timeout rep timeout sorry babe
while your neighbors with your new look
it was pitbull
power dome gets you a head impress your
co-workers and let Greg know who's boss
[Music]
hey don't need to do that
Oh
[Music]
I don't begin to understand what that
was all about
[Laughter]
you